o la estepa de Mongolia,
o la Gran Barrera de Coral
o el Serengeti.
Lugares que creemos que son como representaciones edénicas
de una naturaleza antes de que todo se echara a perder.
Y en cierto modo, se ven menos afectados por nuestro día a día.
Muchos de estos lugares tienen pocos caminos o ninguna carretera.
Pero en última instancia, incluso estos paraísos
están profundamente influenciados por los humanos.
Veamos América del Norte, por ejemplo,
ya que es donde estamos.
Hace unos 15 000 años, cuando la gente llegó por primera vez aquí,
se inició un proceso de interacción con la naturaleza
que llevó a la extinción de muchos animales grandes,
desde el mastodonte al perezoso gigante,
los tigres dientes de sable,
todos estos animales fascinantes que desgraciadamente ya no están con nosotros.
Y cuando esos animales se extinguieron,
los ecosistemas no se detuvieron.
Hubo repercusiones masivas que transformaron pastizales en bosques,
cambiaron la composición del bosque de un árbol a otro.
Así que incluso en estos paraísos,
incluso en estos lugares de apariencia idílica
que parecen recordarnos un pasado anterior a los humanos,
esencialmente vemos un paisaje humanizado.
No solo en la prehistoria, también en las poblaciones indígenas
hasta el momento en que los primeros colonizadores llegaron.
Y el caso es el mismo para los otros continentes.
Los humanos han estado influyendo en la naturaleza
de una manera muy importante durante mucho tiempo.
Hace poco, alguien me dijo,
"Ah, pero todavía hay lugares salvajes".
Y dije, "¿Dónde? ¿Dónde? Quiero ir".
Y me dijo: "El Amazonas".
Y dije, "Oh, el Amazonas. Ya fui.
Es impresionante. National Geographic me envió al Parque Nacional del Manú,
en la Amazonía peruana,
es una gran parte de la selva tropical, no despejada, sin carreteras,
protegida como parque nacional,
de hecho uno de parques con mayor biodiversidad en el mundo.
Y cuando llegué allí con mi canoa lo que encontré fue gente.
La gente ha vivido allí durante cientos y miles de años.
Las personas viven allí y no solo flotan sobre la selva.
Tienen una relación significativa con el paisaje.
Cazan. Cultivan.
Domestican los cultivos.
Utilizan los recursos naturales para construir sus casas,
para techar sus casas.
Incluso tienen mascotas que consideramos animales salvajes.
Estas personas están ahí
e interactúan con el entorno
de una manera muy significativa y que se puede ver en el medio ambiente.
Esa vez viajaba con un antropólogo,
y me dijo, mientras flotábamos en el río,
"No hay vacíos demográficos en la Amazonia".
Esa frase realmente se ha quedado conmigo,
porque lo que quiere decir es que todo el Amazonas es así.
Hay gente por todas partes.
Y en muchos otros bosques tropicales es lo mismo,
y no solo en los bosques tropicales.
La gente ha influido en los ecosistemas en el pasado,
y continúan influyendo sobre ellos en el presente,
incluso en lugares donde es más difícil de notar.
Entonces, si todas las definiciones de la naturaleza
que implican no tener intervención de la humanidad
o no tener gente en ella,
si en realidad se refieren a lugares donde no hay ninguna naturaleza
entonces tal vez tenemos las definiciones equivocadas.
Tal vez deberíamos definirla por la presencia de múltiples especies,
por la presencia de una vida próspera.
Si lo hacemos de esa manera,
¿qué tenemos?
Bueno, este tipo de milagros.
De repente, hay naturaleza a nuestro alrededor
De repente, vemos esta oruga monarca
mascando esta planta,
y nos damos cuenta de que ahí está,
en este terreno baldío en Chattanooga.
Vemos este terreno baldío.
Es decir, hay probablemente como
una docena de, mínimo, especies de plantas que crecen allí,
dándole vida a todo tipo de insectos,
es un espacio sin cuidar, un espacio completamente salvaje.
Es una especie de naturaleza salvaje justo debajo de nuestra nariz,
que ni siquiera notamos.
Es una paradoja interesante también.
Esta naturaleza,
esta parte salvaje, sin cuidar
de nuestra existencia urbana, periurbana, suburbana agrícola
que vuela por debajo del radar,
es sin duda más salvaje que un parque nacional,
porque a los parques nacionales los manejan con mucho cuidado
en el siglo XXI.
El lago Crater en el sur de Oregón, que es el parque nacional más cercano,
es un bello ejemplo de un paisaje que parece salir del pasado.
Pero está manejado con cuidado.
hoy uno de los problemas es la muerte de los pinos de corteza blanca.
El pino de corteza blanca es hermoso, carismático,
diría que es una megaflora carismática
que crece a gran altura,
y tiene todos estos problemas en este momento de enfermedad.
Hay una roya que se introdujo,
un escarabajo de la corteza.
Así que para hacer frente a esto, el servicio de parques ha estado plantando
plántulas de pino de corteza blanca resistentes a la roya en el parque,
incluso en las zonas consideradas salvajes.
Y también están esparciendo repelente de escarabajo en áreas clave
como vi la última vez que fui de excursión allí.
Y estas cosas son realmente muy comunes.
Los parques nacionales están muy regulados.
La vida silvestre se mantiene con una cierta estructura y cantidad de población.
Se apagan los incendios.
Se inician incendios.
Las especies no nativas se eliminan.
Las especies nativas se vuelven a introducir.
Y, de hecho, vi
y el Parque Nacional de Banff hace todo lo que acabo de enumerar:
apagar el fuego, prender fuego,
lobos con radios en sus cuellos, reintroducción de bisontes.
Se necesita mucho trabajo para hacer que estos sitios parezcan intactos.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Y otra ironía, estos lugares que más nos gustan
son los lugares que a veces nos gustan un poco demasiado.
Muchos de nosotros nos gusta ir allí,
y ya que estamos logrando que sean estables
en un planeta cambiante,
a menudo se vuelven cada vez más frágil con el tiempo.
Lo que significa que son los peores lugares
para llevar a sus hijos de vacaciones,
porque no se puede hacer nada allí.
No se pueden subir a los árboles.
No se puede pescar.
No se puede hacer una fogata en medio del bosque.
No se pueden llevar a casa las piñas.
Hay tantas reglas y restricciones
que desde el punto de vista de un niño,
es la peor naturaleza.
Debido a que los niños no quieren ir de excursión
a través de un hermoso paisaje durante cinco horas
y luego ver una hermosa vista.
Eso es quizá lo que queremos hacer como adultos,
pero lo que los niños quieren hacer es estar en un solo lugar
y jugar con él, explorarlo,
recogerlo, construir una casa o un fuerte, hacer algo así.
Además, este tipo de lugares paradisíacos
están a menudo lejos de donde vive la gente.
Y es caro ir ahí. Son difíciles de visitar.
Esto significa que solo están disponibles para las élites,
y eso es un problema real.
The Nature Conservancy hizo un estudio sobre los jóvenes,
y les preguntaron, ¿con qué frecuencia pasas tiempo al aire libre?
Y solo dos de cada cinco pasa tiempo al aire libre
al menos una vez por semana.
Los otros tres de cada cinco solo se quedaban en casa.
Y cuando se les preguntó por qué, cuáles son las barreras para salir,
la respuesta del 61 % fue,
"No hay áreas naturales cerca de mi casa".
Y esto es una mentira. Esto es claramente falso.
Es decir, el 71 % de las personas en los EE.UU.
viven a 10 minutos a pie de un parque de la ciudad.
Y estoy seguro que las cifras son similares en otros países.
Y eso sin contar su jardín trasero,
el arroyo urbano, el solar vacío.
Todo el mundo vive cerca de la naturaleza.
Todo niño vive cerca de la naturaleza.
De alguna manera acabamos olvidando cómo se ve.
Hemos pasado demasiado tiempo viendo documentales de David Attenborough
donde la naturaleza es muy bonita.
y olvidamos la naturaleza que está literalmente justo fuera de nuestra casa,
la naturaleza del árbol de la calle.
Este es un ejemplo: Filadelfia.
Hay un maravilloso ferrocarril elevado
que se puede ver desde el suelo que fue abandonado.
Esto sonaría como el comienzo de High Line en Manhattan,
y es muy similar, excepto que no se ha hecho un parque todavía,
a pesar de que están trabajando en ello.
Así que por ahora, sigue siendo una naturaleza salvaje secreta
en el corazón de Filadelfia,
y si saben dónde está el agujero en la valla de tela metálica,
pueden trepar hasta la cima
y encontrar este prado totalmente salvaje
flotando por sobre la ciudad de Filadelfia.
Cada una de estas plantas creció de una semilla
que se plantó a sí misma allí.
Esta es la naturaleza totalmente autónoma y contumaz.
Y está justo en el medio de la ciudad.
Y han ido personas hasta allí para hacer una especie de bioencuesta,
y hay más de 50 especies de plantas allí.
Y no son solo plantas.
Es un ecosistema, un ecosistema funcional.
Se crea tierra. Se atrapa carbono.
Hay polinización.
Es decir, esto es realmente un ecosistema.
Así que los científicos han comenzado a llamarlos como "nuevos ecosistemas"
porque a menudo están dominados por especies no autóctonas,
y debido a que son muy raros.
Son diferentes de todo lo que hemos visto.
Durante mucho tiempo, hemos desechado estos nuevos ecosistemas como basura.
Estamos hablando de campos agrícolas renaciendo,
plantaciones de árboles que no se cuidan diario,
bosques de segundo crecimiento por toda la costa este,
donde después de que la agricultura se trasladó al oeste, el bosque surgió.
Y, por supuesto, casi todo Hawai,
donde los ecosistemas nuevos son la norma,
donde las especies exóticas dominan totalmente.
Este bosque de aquí tiene arce de Queensland,
tiene helechos de espada del sudeste de Asia.
También pueden hacer su propio ecosistema nuevo.
Es muy sencillo.
Solo no corten el césped.
(Risas)
Ilkka Hanski era un ecologista en Finlandia e hizo este experimento.
Simplemente dejó de cortar el césped,
y después de unos años unos estudiantes de posgrado lo visitaron,
e hicieron un estudio de su patio trasero,
y encontraron 375 especies de plantas,
incluyendo dos especies en peligro de extinción.
Así que cuando estés ahí arriba en ese futuro High Line de Filadelfia,
rodeado de la naturaleza salvaje,
rodeado de esta diversidad, esta abundancia, esta vitalidad,
puedes mirar a un lado
y ver un parque local para una escuela local
y así se ve.
Estos niños tienen que,
ya saben, en mi definición
una gran parte del planeta la considero como naturaleza,
pero esto sería uno de los pocos lugares que no contaría como naturaleza.
No hay nada allí, excepto humanos, no hay otras plantas ni animales.
Y lo que realmente quería hacer
era poner una escalera al lado
y hacer que todos esos niños vinieran a este prado estupendo.
En cierto modo, siento que esta es la disyuntiva que encaramos.
Si descartamos estas nuevas naturalezas como no aceptables o de mala calidad
puede ser que acabemos por pavimentarlos.
Y en un mundo donde todo cambia,
tenemos que ser muy cuidadosos sobre cómo definimos la naturaleza.
Con el fin de no robarles a nuestros hijos,
tenemos que hacer dos cosas.
En primer lugar, no podemos definir la naturaleza como aquello que es virgen.
Esto nunca tuvo sentido de todos modos.
A la naturaleza la han tocado desde hace miles de años.
Y que excluye la mayor parte de lo que la mayoría de la gente puede visitar
y relacionarse,
incluyendo solo la naturaleza que los niños no pueden tocar.
Lo que me lleva a lo segundo que tenemos que hacer,
y es que hay que dejar que los niños toquen la naturaleza,
porque lo que es virgen no se ama.
(Aplausos)
Nos enfrentamos a algunos desafíos ambientales muy severos en este planeta.
El cambio climático es uno de ellos.
Hay otros también: la pérdida de hábitat es algo
con lo que me gusta asustar en medio de la noche.
Sin embargo, con el fin de resolverlos,
necesitamos personas, gente inteligente dedicada,
que se preocupe por la naturaleza.
Y la única forma para lograrlo es educando a una generación
que se preocupe por la naturaleza,
dejándoles tocar la naturaleza.
Tengo una teoría de la fortaleza de ecología,
La teoría del fuerte de conservación.
Cada ecologista que conozco, todos los biólogos de conservación que conozco,
cada profesional de la conservación que conozco,
construía fortalezas cuando eran niños.
Si tenemos una generación que no sabe cómo construir un fuerte,
tendremos una generación que no sabrá cómo cuidar de la naturaleza.
Y yo no quiero ser quien le diga a este niño
que está en un programa especial
que lleva a los niños de los barrios pobres de Filadelfia
a los parques de la ciudad,
no quiero ser quien le diga que la flor que sostiene
es una maleza invasora no nativa que debería tirar como basura.
Creo que me gustaría mucho aprender de este chico
que no importa de dónde provenga esta planta,
es hermosa y que merece ser tocada y apreciada.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)